i actually think we could get that at
twelve hundred twelve hundred
yeah
i think it's that far out of whack
twelve hundred would be below historic
there's people right now who are gonna
hear you say that and they're gonna go
shut their computer and what go for a
walk outside well this
next recession
will be a killer because we have too
much debt
the federal reserve has no ammo to fake
our way out of it
um those three things that occurred
four or five things that occurred
momentously over the last 40 years that
won't repeat
one of the things they did is they
created an equity market it was this
relentless series
of v bounces
so the market would try to correct
and then it would bounce right back
and someone who says that a 20 drop that
rallies back to where it was before
within a year
if you want to call it a correction have
a ball it corrected
nothing precisely nothing all it did was
reinforce the idea
that you can't lose investing in stocks
now oh guy you want to pay attention to
very very off radar off screen uh he's
got him at macquarie at uc irvine and
he's analyzed markets back a couple
hundred years
and and he talks about you know equities
and bonds
they break even ben graham said that too
they break even they
the only
if you take the bond market disaster
post world war ii
you know mid a couple of decades there
the 200 years
equities and bonds tie each other and
set and and graham said anyone who who
thinks equities necessarily be
bonds in return
is delusional
now maybe maybe things have changed now
but regression of the mean will occurred
always does
and if you look at something that's way
way way off any sort of historical
metric
i don't know when but you got to assume
it's going to regress
i the bet as to when is dangerous but
the bet to bet that it won't progress
that's the most dangerous
yeah it uh the it's the mean for a
reason
right yes
yeah in fact it's in fact what the fed
has done is prevented it from from ever
going below the mean you know the
markets weren't even that cheap unknow
they they they were below fair value for
about a month
and i said that when i was at a dinner
with um
mark spitznagel who's one of these deep
zen types um and he concurred and jeremy
grantham too they both said look they
were below fair value for the the
shortest period of time
so so if the horrific collapse of
everything caused the markets to spend
a month below fair historical fair value
what did you correct
and people you know when the markets
were down 20
people would ask me colleagues ah the
markets are about 20 i'm getting real
nervous i said okay
if a year and a half ago
i told you that you would not make any
money over the next year and a half
would you have your pants
the answer is no
they say yeah that would be fine well i
said that's what you just did
but the message also is we haven't
corrected anything we unwound a year and
a half of fraud
we haven't even gotten back to the i'm
not even sure we're back to the
pre-kovit peak
which was already a disastrously high
peak
and uh so i think we're going to unwind
i think the s p is going to unwind sub 2
000. hey you did you like this video
great make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time